the only way to do great work is to love
what you
do it's not about money or connections
it's the willingness to outwork and out
learn everyone when it comes to your
business if you don't build your dreams
someone else will hire you to help them
build theirs
I have not failed I've just found 10,000
ways that don't
work I believe in Innovation and the way
you get Innovation is you fund research
and you learn the basic
[Music]
facts the best way to predict your
future is to create
it the difference between successful
people and very successful people is
that very successful people say no to
almost
everything you don't have to be great to
start but you have to start to be
great don't let yesterday take up too
much of
today I knew that if I failed I would
regret it but I knew the one thing I
might regret is not
trying I can accept failure everyone
fails at something but I can't accept
not
trying if you want to achieve greatness
stop asking for
permission Innovation distinguishes
between a leader and a follower
believe you can and you're halfway
there chase the vision not the money the
money will follow
you if you really look closely most
overnight successes took a long
time you don't learn to walk by
following rules
you learn by doing and by falling
over the only thing worse than starting
something and failing is not starting
something a successful man is one who
can lay a firm foundation with the
bricks others have thrown at
him success is not the absence of
failure it's the persistence through
failure Success is Not final failure is
not fatal it is the courage to continue
that
counts the only limit to our realization
of Tomorrow will be our doubts of
today in order to be
Irreplaceable one must be
different
your most unhappy customers are your
greatest source of
learning the best revenge is massive
success the biggest risk is not taking
any risk in a world that's changing
quickly the only strategy that is
guaranteed to fail is not taking
risks
the best investment you can make is in
yourself if you want to be successful
you have to work hard for
it I never dreamed about success I
worked for
it the only place where success comes
before work is in the
dictionary
success is not the key to happiness
happiness is the key to success if you
love what you are doing you will be
successful you miss 100% of the shots
you don't
take success is walking from failure to
failure with no loss of
enthusiasm the the only person you are
destined to become is the person you
decide to
become the more you know yourself the
more clarity there is self- knowledge
has no
end don't watch the clock do what it
does keep
advancing I attribute My Success to this
I never gave gave or took any
excuse success is not in what you have
but who you
are don't be afraid to give up the good
to go for the
great success is not how high you have
climbed but how you make a positive
difference to the
world strive not to be a success rather
to be a
value if you can't fly then run if you
can't run then walk if you can't walk
then crawl but whatever you do you have
to keep moving
forward the greatest wealth is to live
content with
little if you want to be successful ful
find someone who has achieved the
results you want and copy what they
do a penny saved is a penny
earned fortune favors the
Bold it is impossible to live without
failing at something unless you live so
cautiously that you might as well not
live at all in which case case you have
failed by
default all you have in business is your
reputation it's important that you keep
your
word it's fine to celebrate success but
it is more important to heed the lessons
of
failure I don't know why you should be
proud of something it doesn't make you
any better or worse you are what you
are you can worry about the competition
or you can focus on what's ahead of you
and drive
fast if you don't find a way to make
money while you sleep you will work
until you
die never give up today is hard tomorrow
will be worse but the day after After
Tomorrow Will Be
Sunshine no action is too small when it
comes to changing the world I'm inspired
every time I meet an entrepreneur who is
succeeding Against All
Odds if you are born poor it's not your
mistake but if you die poor it is your
mistake when the rate of change outside
is more than what is inside be sure that
the end is
near when it comes to decisions I try
not to be emotional drown out the noise
and look at the important
facts Sweat Equity is the most valuable
Equity there is know your business and
industry better than anyone else in the
world love what you do or don't do it
[Music]
if I'm going to do something I do it
spectacularly or I don't do it at
all part of being a Winner Is Knowing
When enough is enough sometimes you have
to give up the fight and walk away and
move on to something that's more
productive as I grow older I pay less
attention to what men say
I just watch what they
do don't let the noise of others
opinions drown out your own inner voice
and most important have the courage to
follow your heart and
intuition I think frugality drives
Innovation just like other constraints
do one of the ways to get out of a tight
box is to invent your way out
if you want to succeed you should strike
out on New Paths rather than travel the
warn Paths of accepted
success if you want to do something
different you're going to come up
against a lot of
naysayers as you start your journey the
first thing you should do is throw away
that store-bought map and begin to draw
your own
when you innovate you've got to be
prepared for everyone telling you you're
nuts complacency is the worst I never
allow myself to be content with what I
have done and I always try to instill
this in everyone around
me especially in technology we need
revolutionary change not incremental
change if people are not laughing at
your goals your goals are too
small the more you praise and celebrate
your life the more there is in life to
celebrate what God intended for you goes
far beyond anything you can
imagine I think that our fundamental
belief is that for us growth is a way of
life and we have to keep
growing one of the things I'm trying to
get better at is apologizing when I make
mistakes that's been a big priority of
mine become a millionaire not for the a
million dollar but for what it will make
of you to achieve
it loyalty is not one by being first it
is one by being
best you can never quit winners never
quit and quitters never
win low interest rates are a big
opportunity for
investment but they the issue is that
this money should go to the real economy
not the financial
economy the worse a situation becomes
the less it takes to turn it around the
bigger the
upside I've never chased money it's
always been about what I can do to
motivate and inspire
people a wise person should have money
in their head but not in their
heart the reason I've been able to be so
financially successful is my focus has
never ever for one minute been about
money the quickest way to double your
money is to fold it in half and put it
in your back
pocket people should only profit to the
extent
they make other people's lives
better when you have money in your hand
only you forget who you are but when you
do not have money in your hand the whole
world forgets who you are that's
life wealth isn't the same thing as
intelligence I will tell you the secret
to getting rich on Wall Street
you try to be greedy when others are
fearful and you try to be fearful when
others are
greedy thank you for watching which
quote did you like best let us know in
the
comments